foreign
artificial neural networks to learn from
large complex data sets and make
Productions or decisions
deep learning algorithms are designed to
extract features and patterns from the
input data allowing tasks such as
production neural language processing
and image and speech recognization to be
performed
deep learning has drastically
transformed how we process analyze and
make data-driven decisions making it
necessary skills for anyone interested
in artificial intelligence data science
or machine learning phytos expands the
capabilities of the machine learning
framework it will further provide high
speed in deep neural network
implementation hey everyone you're
watching simply learn and in today's
video we're going to be learning all
about deep learning with python if you
love watching videos like this do hit
the Subscribe button to never miss any
updates from Simply learn if you want to
become an expert in the field of EI and
machine learning consider professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning by simplylearn and Masters
those necessary skills check out the
link in the description for more details
first let us understand how we spy touch
used in deep learning next let's look at
the advantages and disadvantages of deep
learning using pythost and finally let's
build one layer hidden fed forward
neural network
deep learning with pie torch is popular
in artificial intelligence and machine
learning it is a user-friendly platform
for developing and training deep
learning models deep neural network can
be implemented and trained using pi
torch to perform complex Stars such as
speech and image recognition natural
language processing and other machine
learning tasks so now let us understand
how is python used in deep learning so
it is used in building and training
neural networks data processing and
manipulations transfer learning and
visualization so let us know each in
detail building and training neural
networks is Made Simple by pytorch wide
range of pre-built layers activation
function launch functions and
optimization algorithm its dynamic
computational graphs makes gradient
competition flexible and efficient
making it simple to implement
complicated models next we have data
processing and manipulation
so to transform unstructured data into
useful information pytouch provides
various tools for data processing and
manipulation large data set can be
processed and loaded quickly with the
help of these tools keeping the data
more useful for use in deep learning
models it improves the Precision and
caliber of the model then
transfer learning phytos offers a
variety of features and tools to Aid in
transfer learning and it also makes it
simple to put those features into
practice it entails starting a new task
with a pre-trained model that can be
used for transfer learning in just a few
lines of code next visualization some
built-in visualization Tools in pie
touch allow for the visualizations of
training results graphs of accuracy as
well as loss and visualizations of the
model's production when integrated with
other libraries Fighters can be useful
for developing visualizations for deep
learning applications
so now we know how python is used in
deep learning so advancing let's look at
the advantages and disadvantages of deep
learning using pytorch pytouch is used
widely in the research and development
of deep learning models and here are
some advantages of deep learning using
pytots
due to its straightforward interface
python is simple to use which make it
simple for developers to use and learn
it's to use a friendly framework and
clear syntax make it easy to use next
fighter chooses robust python tools and
libraries like numpy to create models
and handle data processing
it allows developers to design unique
models layers and loss functions
supports neural network architectures
and transform as well
with the help of Python's Dynamic
computational graph models can be built
and modified easily making debugging
simpler
and in order to handle large data sets
and build models across GPU or CPU
devices python chooses distributed
computing
pythons offers strong visualization
tools to visualize deep learning models
performance during training therefore
pytos offers a strong framework for
creating deep learning models and a
variety of tools for training models if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
next we have disadvantages of deep
learning using Phi Dodge
first the hardware needed for deep
learning models such as GPU device can
be costly
and debugging the Deep learning models
can be difficult when the data set is
large and complex
deep learning models need a lot of data
to perform accurately which may not be
possible in some applications
and then deploying model interpretations
can be challenging making comprehensive
how the model makes production difficult
now let's build one layer of hidden fit
forward neural network
a forward neural network is a neural
network architecture with a single
hidden layer of neurons between the
input and output layers the input layer
receives input data in this architecture
and the output layer produces output and
the hidden layer transforms the input
data non-linearly and provides a higher
level representations of the input to
the output layer typically the number of
neurons in the hidden layer is
determined by Trail or error or through
some sort of optimization process
so now let's start
so the first step is to import all
necessary libraries to ensure that all
the tools are available so first let's
import
torch
next import
torch dot Ln as nn
then import
torch vision
next import
Dot
transform
transforms as transforms
next
import
smash plot
live
Dot
type plot
as PLT
Next Step device configuration so use
the GPU for the computation if available
otherwise use the CPU so for that let's
type device
is equal to torch
dot device
inside this will put two down
if available
if Dodge dot go down
dot is available
else will go with the
CPU
so next using parameters let's train a
neural network so for that we'll give
input
size
is equal to
so image size is 28 by 28 that is one
dimensional tensor
so total will be 28 by 28 will be 784 so
input size will be 784 then hidden size
will be 100
so we can Define different size and then
we can give number of classes is equal
to 10
so number of classes are always 10 so we
have 0 to 9 so we give 10.
and then we have number of
keyports
will give to
and then badge size
is equal to 100
and learning rate
zero point
zero zero one
okay next import famous MNS data set so
for that we'll give train
data set is equal to
rch vision
dot data sets
Dot mnist
if
the root
so it is in
folder data
train is equal to true
comma
give transform
is equal to
transform
transforms to
tensor
comma download
foreign
and then transforms is equal to
transforms dot to tensor and here we
will not download it
okay
so next let's print the data set for
train and test
for that give print
data set
and here we got and also let's give
print
test data set
so mnist is a popular data set for
machine learning and computer vision
applications it is a collection of 70
000 normalized and centralized
handwritten digits 0 to 9 within a fixed
size image so each image is 28 pixels
wide by 28 pixels high for a total of
784 pixels so here you can see we have
uh in train dataset we have 60 000 and
test data set we have 10 000.
and the data set is commonly used for
digit recognization task in which the
goal is to correctly classify each digit
image into its numerical value the MNS
data set is frequently used to compare
the performance of various machine
learning algorithms particularly for
classification tasks so now next step
let's create a data loader object called
train loader which is used to load the
data in batches so for that let's give
Trail loader
is equal to
torch Dot
utils dot data Dot
data loader
and or data set is equal to
train data
train data set
command
batch size
is equal to
cash size
come on
Shuffle is equal to true
and same goes with the test loader so
let's keep
test loader dot utils dot data dot data
loader and here data set is equal to
test data set
and batch size is equal to batch size
and then
Shuffle is equal to false
okay
so next create an iterated object so
these
example
examples is equal to either
train loader
so examples from a train loader object
it is
different samples
comma labels
is equal to its samples
dot next
so call the next method and then
print
samples Dot
shape
comma
labels
dot shape
so here we'll print the size of the
sample
samples is not defined
in
okay so here we got the output
so in output we call the size of the
samples where batch size is 100 and
color channel is 1 and image size is 28
by 28 so label tensor of size is 100.
next import
my
plot lip
dot p y p l o t as PLT
so for I in range
of 6.
so here we are create uh so creating a
figure with eight subplots organizing
two rows or eight columns so two rows
and eight columns it is so each subplot
shows an image from the samples so for
uh showing rows and columns will give
no
subplot
comma 6
comma I Plus 1.
so here it indicates one row and six
columns and index is I Plus 1.
or sometimes it will multiply the
numbers and display that many images so
it's like one one into six like six
images it will display
so if you give 2 into 6 it will display
12 images
next
Dot
IM sure using that info method
samples
of I
of 0
and C color mapping it is
is equal to 3.
so when displaying the image in Gray
scales the color mapping parameters
specifies the color map to use
so
let's give
flat Dot
prevent the code from beginning
so here we got
so if you want to change the color
so suppose if I give
so this is also a color Channel
so you have got in a different color
or you can also give one of these
and here we've got
in different color
so here we gave six
so we got six images so suppose you want
to give eight
so let's give eight
and here we got eight images so these
are the images from samples
next let's define the class from NN
model
so for that give class
neural network neural net
and then dot module
steps
method in it
two inch lies
self comma
input size comma hidden size
number of classes
then Super
your left
commercial
calling init method
then self Dot
layer 1 is equal to NN dot module and in
dot linear
input size
and we are giving hidden size
dot value
is there any function
is equal equal to
and then dot value
and self dot layer 2
is equal to NN Dot
linear
hidden size
comma number of classes
in so here the neural net class inherits
from the NN module class so here we have
given in module and which is the base
class for all neural network modules in
pytots and then we are using the init so
the init method initialize the neural
network by creating and initializing its
layers so which we have here L1 and L2
layer and also we have one a relu
activation function function which is
this rplu and then the first layer
that is here
so the first linear layer takes an input
tensor and produces an output tensor of
size input size and while the second
layer takes the output of the value
function which is of the size hidden
size and produces the tensor of size num
classes
so next
step forward
self comma X
out is equal to
self
dot linear layer 1 of x
then out is equal to
self Dot
value
of out
is equal to
cell Dot
L2 of out
and then return on
so here the method takes a tensor X as
an input and applies two layers that is
selfie layer 1 and the self layer 2.
so and rectify silly a linear unit that
is a activation function to it and the
output of the first layer is passed
through the value attribution function
so this is passed here
and then the final output is the output
of the second layer output
and then we print the output
so after this create a neural network
model using the neural net class so for
that we'll if model is equal to
neural net
of input size
comma return size
and number of classes
yeah
so the input size is a hidden size and
the number of Clauses and the output
size are the number of neurons in the
neural network hidden layer so here
input size is the size of the input data
vector and hidden size is the
intermediate layer between the input and
output layers and the output class is a
number of classes in the classification
problem
so next we'll give
Criterion
foreign
Dot
cross
entropy
loss
of Optimizer is equal to
rch Dot optim
um
model Dot
parameters
common dining right that is l i is equal
to
pluraling away
so here this piece of code sets up the
training process for the neural network
model in pie torch using the Adam
Optimizer and we are using the cross
entropy laws as the objective function
and next training the loop so we will
check the number of total steps so for
that n
foreign
step
is equal to
length of
train loader
so it is a length of the training order
for
import
in range
number of approaches
and fourth
High comma
images comma labels
enumerate
train Builder
next game
so it enumerates over the train loader
next reshape the tensor for that give
images is equal to
images dot e shape
dimensional First Dimension minus one
comma 28 by 28
giving it to device
labels
is equal to labels Dot to device
next initializing a gradient at 0 so
there is no mixing of gradient among the
patches so we'll give
optimizer
Dot
zero Gray
and loss
so propagating the error backboard gives
laws backward
foreign
Optimizer dot step
let's give it in one
single block
okay let's check that
will give if
5 plus 1
percent
100 is equal to
equal equal to 0
then print
the reports
the ports plus one
divided by
third of the purchase
sixth step
I plus 1
divided by
n number of total steps
for my loss
is equal to
loss dot item
so here for every 100 step during
training the current e-ports current
step and loss value are printed
so next
let's keep
with thoughts
DOT number of three
and then n cut it
is equal to 0
number of samples
is equal to zero
and for
images comma labels
in
test loader
images is equal to
images Dot
T shape
minus 1 comma 28 by 28
so let's send it to
device
next labels
is equal to
labels dot to device
output is equal to
more images
model
and then give
Productions
is equal to torch
dot Max
of
outputs comma 1
and N number of samples
Plus or equal to labels
dot shape of 0
10 correct
Plus or equal to
red
predictions
is equal equal to
labels
dot sum
dot item
then give
ACC is equal to 100
of
any number of having
divided by n number of samples
ring
accuracy
thank you
so here the outputs variable contain the
predicted output of the neural network
for the given data set and the torch.max
outputs comma 1 this function retains
the maximum value in its index so the
prediction variable is set the predicted
class index for each sample in the data
set and the end samples variable keeps
the track of the total number of samples
in the data set and the incorrect
variable calculates the number of
samples for which the predicted class
matches the true label and the accuracy
is calculated as a percentage of the
correct Productions
foreign
so here it says the name loss is not
defined
foreign
so the error is name loss is not defined
so here let's add a piece of code
so outputs
is equal to model of images
and
loss is equal to
Criterion
of
outputs common levels
so now let's run it
so there is no proper spacing here
somewhere
so let's run it
and here we got the Emojis steps and the
laws so I use pie torch to implement
deep learning neural network using the
mnips data set for digit classification
and the accuracy of the model that is
code is 97.53
so if you want to you know increase the
accuracy you can change or modify the
layer architecture or the parameters
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more and with that
we come to the end of this video you on
deep learning with pytots so if you like
this video share it with your friends
and before I sign off make sure you
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to get all the updates we'll
be back with more such interesting
videos until then keep learning and stay
tuned to Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here